there was a woman who was dragged out of
a town hall meeting in West Virginia
simply for listing the corporate donors
of politicians I've jokingly but not I
mean I guess I'm not really joking when
I say it politicians should display
their corporate donors sort of like
NASCAR drivers do either on the front of
their lecterns when they speak or in
some other way so that we know who's
funding them right who has donated money
to these politicians and Lisa Lucas went
to the West Virginia State House to
testify against the bill sponsored by
the oil and gas industry called HB 4268
and it would let fossil fuel companies
drill on the land of small mineral
owners without their consent and what
when I saw this I thought wait wait a
second I thought right-wingers were all
about the sovereignty of land ownership
and land owners but they want a bill
that would let corporations use the
resources of that private land without
consent desert doesn't really make sense
part of that double standard from the
right but that's not the story here the
story is that Lisa Lucas showed up and
she said hey listen um the people who
want this garbage Bill got money from
the company companies that will profit
from it and she started reading who got
the money from these oil companies and
gas companies and she was told to stop
and eventually she was physically
removed from the room check this out
take a listen I'd also like to point out
that the people who are going to be
speaking in favor of this bill are all
going to be paid by the industry and
people who are going to be voting on
this bill are also often paid by the
industry for example and I have to keep
it short simply because the public only
gets a minute 45 while lobbyists can
throw a gala at the Marriott with
whiskey and wine and talk for hours to
the delegates so to keep it short on the
Judiciary Committee Charlotte Leigh
about $10,000 from gas and oil interest
including a EP marathon first Energy
Dominion eqt and I could go on next
let's talk about John shot from Mercer
first energy $2,000 Appalachian Power
$2,000
step two in Johnson that's a gas and oil
law firm $2,000 console energy 1,000 eqt
1,000 and I could go on now let's talk
about Jason Hershberger miss Henkes we
asked no personal comments be made if
you don't talk about still comment is a
personal comment and I'm going to call
you out of order if you're talking about
individuals on the committee so if you
would just address the bill that's not
you know I asked you to please step down
took $3,500 out remove 40%
right
[Music]
[Music]
the next speaker would be Julie Archer
right so you heard the phrase personal
comments right they said listen you're
allowed to talk about the bill but not
about specific people involved with the
bill this is a totally arbitrary way to
try to suppress this type of information
right I mean any reasonable person
understands if you're involved with the
bill you're a big part of the bill but
because that's considered personal she
gets dragged off here I actually think
this is a great strategy for political
activism it can be really hard to show
up at public comment periods at the
local and state level and really make an
impact if you show up and you just start
arguing about the politics of a bill
you're probably not going to change a
lot of minds what about the idea of
showing up and doing exactly what Lisa
Lucas did which is you come prepared
with a list of who received money from
whom and you say I want to tell you that
this is the amount of money that these
people got from one side of this and
that actually could could transcend
party lines and appeal to everybody who
is sort of against the crony capitalist
system of political financing that we
have make it about the money because
they don't want you to know that it's
about the money put it front and center
and good for Lisa here and by the way
she is running for in the Democratic
primary in West Virginia 7th district
you can look her up
it's Lisa Lucas Lisa with two S's and
you know the the bad news is that the
bill that Lisa was testifying against
did make it out of committee it's
expected to pass both the House and
Senate and it's eventually expected to
be signed into law by the governor
Republican Jim Justice and it's going to
be disastrous for the environment but
congratulations to Lisa for doing
something good there should be more of
this and I think that this this is
something we should start doing a
nationwide we've got a great bonus show
for you today we're going to talk about
Westerners deported from Cambodia for
their dancing we will talk about a big
change to the way that oxycontin is
going to be marketed and also another
tipping related Fiasco this time
involving a Florida
megachurch all those stories and more on
today's bonus show don't miss the bonus
show for Members Only at david
pakman.com slash membership and for
patrons at the $5 a month level at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
thanks for listening thanks for watching
we'll talk to you then